a plea for a 21st century Marshall Plan
for Ukraine similar to what the United
States designed to rebuild Western
Europe after World War II it's the
strongest the destruction is measurable
the suffering in the country is great
estimates of extent of a damage vary
widely it's probably already many
hundreds of billions of Euros in the
medium term however the issue will be
reconstruction the destroyed houses and
roads will have to be rebuilt the
factories repaired this is a task for
generations to come
addressing the conference from Kiev
urged countries and donors to stick to
their promises National fast recovery
plan our first recovery plan is 17
billion dollars for critical immediate
reconstruction these are hospitals
schools vital transport and energy
infrastructure it is necessary to give
people a new base for life already now
they have not yet received a single Cent
for the implementation of the fast
recovery plan I urge you to soon make
the necessary decisions the U.S and the
EU have each said they will pay Ukraine
1.5 billion dollars a month to keep the
country running but to rebuild Ukraine a
lot more is needed the main question
here in Berlin is who will finance a
reconstruction of Ukraine since the
start of the war the United States has
spent billions of dollars mostly for
military assistance now there's a lot of
pressure on the European Union to
deliver we know how difficult the
economic situation is for Europeans and
Americans High inflation high energy
costs High Cost of Living costs this is
where leadership comes in this is where
our political leaders have to have a
very honest conversation with their
citizens and the message for me for this
conference is the cost of of helping
Ukraine now is is small in comparison to
if Ukraine fails since Russia invaded
Ukraine an estimated 300 billion dollars
of Russian assets have been frozen
worldwide the EU has been looking into
legal ways to confiscate these assets so
they can be used to rebuild Ukraine but
experts say there may be too many legal
and political obstacles for this to
happen stop fasten Al Jazeera Berlin